hay que encontrar el justo medio entre
acelerar y calmar por ratos tomarse su
tiempo y esperar por los desplazamientos
de sus compañeras
al final estuvo muy bien felicitaciones
desde su llegada a impuesto su sello
combinar exigencia y alentar el ex
entrenador de Arabia Saudita que logró
Con este equipo una histórica Victoria
ante Argentina en el mundial de fútbol
de Qatar trajo consigo nuevos Aires y
reitera cuán Contento está de haber sido
elegido en este nuevo cargo
me siento muy a gusto y es una gran
suerte para mí el estar aquí
las francesas salen de un periodo
difícil que terminó con la renuncia de
varias jugadoras emblemáticas tras
oponerse al método de indiac quien
dirigía al equipo desde 2017 en apenas
unos días la complicidad entre el doble
campeón de la Copa africana de Naciones
y las jugadoras salta a la vista
tiene mucho conocimiento de lo que
sucede en otros países tiene lo vivido y
la experiencia
hablamos mucho con él es alguien muy
abierto
las reivindicaciones de las jugadoras
que se rebelaron fueron escuchadas ahora
la selección cuenta con un staff más
amplio y abierto al diálogo seis
personas conforman el cuerpo técnico
ya sea en las sesiones lo que plantean
los ejercicios sentimos un cambio
directamente es un cambio positivo para
nosotras es de alto nivel Hay que decir
la verdad cuando vemos grandes equipos
los que ganan campeonatos a nivel
europeo copas del mundo todos tienen un
amplio staff esta nueva era comienza con
el pie derecho con dos victorias en
partidos amistosos contra Colombia y
Canadá Hace unos días su preparación
para el mundial de fútbol en Australia y
Nueva Zelanda ya aprendió motores el
objetivo para este verano es claro y
manifiesto dar al fútbol femenino
francés su primer título mundial